[Applause]
good afternoon i'm jeremy brock welcome
to our fifth screenwriters lecture
in conjunction with lucy garden the jj
charitable trust
um i am enormously honored to announce
that our next speaker
is the internationally renowned lebanese
filmmaker nadine levacky
her films include caramel where do we go
now
and the stunningly poignant
kaepernium winner of the grand jury
prize at the 2018 cannes film festival
nadine will give a talk
followed by a q a with the british
council's director of film brony hansen
after which we will as we always do open
it up to questions from the floor
so ladies and gentlemen nadine
hi
um
i want to start by
really thanking you for being here
uh thanking uh everyone everybody who
invited me here for this great honor you
know i'm
this is my first time
i'm i'm doing a lecture
i've never really done this before so i
don't i don't really consider myself to
be a screenwriter i
i do it because
i need to do it because i i want to
express myself through
the films i do
so i don't know if what i'm going to say
is actually going to be a lecture i'm
just going to
simply
share my experience with you this small
experience i've had i've done three
films until now
uh i've done caramel where do we go now
and capernaum i don't know i don't know
if
[Music]
you've seen them all
so that's what i'm going to be basically
doing sharing my experience that it
doesn't need to be it doesn't have to be
the right one but it's my way
of
of making films especially
when you grow up in lebanon where
there's no film industry
back then when i started
doing my first film
and dreaming about
working in this field there was no films
being done so so i really
learned as i went
i really learned with my first film and
i almost learned lured my producer
producer into thinking that i was
actually
able to make a film when i didn't really
know
how to even write a screenplay so so
it's it's really i learned
my craft as i started working so um
i just want to start from
maybe from the beginning
i am going to be also talking about
not only the screenwriting but also the
the filmmaking process and the editing
process because for me
they sort of complement each other
complete
each other's because
uh for me it's like uh it's the writing
process contin continues till the last
moment the film keeps uh being rewritten
as we
as we uh evolve
into into this adventure until the last
moment really
uh so i'm gonna go back
a little bit to how this whole adventure
for me started
in in making films um
i grew up in a war-torn country lebanon
and growing up in in during the war i
think um
you know you don't really have a normal
childhood
we used to spend
a lot of time
uh in shelters we used to spend a lot of
time at home
you know with
[Music]
sand bags
obstructing
our windows so so there was uh
boredom was a really big part of my
childhood
of course apart from the fact that of
course there's fear of
not knowing what's going to happen
tomorrow and all this anxiety but also
boredom because we couldn't play outside
we couldn't
we couldn't sometimes go to school for a
very long time
so i think the tv set that was right in
the middle of this of of of the
living room be started becoming very
important in my life and
and um
it was a time also because of the war
that there was no power most of the time
so we used to the highlight of our day
actually for my sister and i was the
time that there was actually power and
that we can actually be able to watch
tv
and we used to really devour everything
that was on tv
watching anything uh
sometimes stupid tv series
egyptian films uh american series i i
learned actually english by watching
dallas and dynasty
yes i was a big fan
i remember very well how i made my first
connection between
the word baby that i heard from somebody
talking and reading in arabic
baby so this is how i started doing the
connection between what i heard and what
i read and that's how i learned english
really
so i was the first one in class when we
started english later
on anyway so for me
uh really uh
film started becoming a very big part of
my life very important part of my life
it really because i also we were very
lucky because we used to live above
a video rental store small video rental
store so we used to sneak behind the
sandbags and go inside and to spend
hours
hours renting and and looking at films
and choosing films and sometimes renting
the same films over and over again
because there was no big choice during
the war and so we used to watch the same
films also until
again and again until the the the vhs
tape was completely destroyed
um and watching films like ferris
bueller's day off like greece like
annie
i remember back to the future um
it really allowed me to escape the
reality i used to live in escape like it
allowed me to experiment life
differently to
to in a way
empathize with characters to live
different stories to
to
understand dance and music
more
to really dream and really escape the
boredom of my childhood so when i
discovered that to be able actually to
to create the stories that those stories
that have nothing to do with my own
story in order to do that i had to
become a filmmaker i decided very early
that this is what i want to do in life i
want to become a filmmaker i want to
write stories i want to be able to dream
i
i want to escape
escape through films
and i told my father very early i want
to make films and at that point there
was no films being done at all because
of the war of course it was the industry
was completely dead so of course he
smiled and said yes because in a way
i was also
realizing his dream because my my
grandfather used to have a
movie theater very humble movie theater
in the village where my father was born
and i remember how my father used to
tell me that she used to go to that
movie theater and spend so much time in
the projection room
uh dreaming through those images that he
used to see
on the big screen
in a way i sort of maybe inherited this
from him and my sister is also doing the
same thing so
we've inherited this love of you know
storytelling and and filmmaking
um i don't know if i should be telling
you this but
uh
uh
so
so when i
but then when i obviously i went to i
went to film school and i after i
finished film school um
i wanted to learn my craft i wanted to
see how how do how do we how do we
actually how do we learn it but
unfortunately there was no
uh
film industry in the real sense of that
there was no films being shot so i
couldn't really go on a set and see
other filmmakers work or
or other filmmakers um
you know do their thing and and
understand the rules and and how it
actually function and how the structure
works and all that so so i started uh
working in advertising this is
advertising became in a way my my lab
this is how i i learned things i
experimented things
so when i
really started dreaming of making my my
first film i didn't know how to tackle
it i really
for me i i learned i learned my producer
into into into thinking that into making
her believe that i can actually make a
film when i really didn't know how to
make a film so i started learning as i
went and i created i think my own way of
working
it doesn't have to be the right way but
it worked for me
it worked for me which is a mixture
between of course having a very solid
script
but then later on working
with non-professional actors bringing
people from real life
asking them to be and not to really act
because i truly believe that
when you're watching somebody who's
actually living that same life on the
big screen or living almost the same
life on the big screen it has a
completely different impact on you as a
viewer
knowing that this struggle is actually a
real struggle
i think you leave the theater with a
completely different
impact
so
so i first of all the script writing uh
the screenwriting um
experience had to be
fun for me so
i i i i didn't want to feel like i was
working for me it's it's i'm not a very
disciplined person so for me to be
writing on my own
uh was somehow very um
painful i i didn't know how to really
talk to myself so so for me it was very
important that i share
that i talk that i put those ideas out
there and that i debate with somebody
else so this this ping-pong effect was
very important for me so we started
writing
with my friends and it's the human
connection of course
is is very important so i started
writing with one of my best friends in
the beginning and then and then the
group starting getting bigger started
getting bigger and
and so
for me it's really
writing at home is very important
because it allows me to be of course
being a mother
it allows me to be close to my children
and
not
feeling that i'm really working so so
during the writing process there's a lot
of other things also happening a lot of
breastfeeding a lot of to
diaper changing a lot of
napping uh
time a lot of uh
also sharing you know eating together um
a lot of coffee and tea drinking so so
it's not a very
no discipline is actually the word it's
not a very disciplined and structured
way of working sometimes we spend
really hours or the whole day at home
just talking about something else
something that has nothing to do with
the film but i think that's
i i i started feeling more creative
when i was actually talking about an
idea putting the idea out there and
debating and it actually allowed me to
have a very direct
reaction to the idea because you have
also
a viewer you have some kind of a sort of
a viewer in front of you you're debating
you're
so i think it was it was it's very
important for me that i i am surrounded
with people when i'm when i'm working
and that we are debating about it
uh later on uh so i did of course my two
uh first and and actually when i
when we started working i didn't like i
told you i didn't really know
if we were doing things the right way so
we really like invented a way of working
and when i actually had my first the
the script of caramel in my hands i
couldn't believe my eyes you know it was
beautiful binded and all that i couldn't
believe that i was actually able
to write 90 pages because i think it was
like 90 pages of a film
i i i started doing it not really
believing that i was ever going to
finish that film and i was actually we
finished it and we shot it and it was a
beautiful trim that went to
toucan and it was a very big success and
it sold all over the world but maybe
also it has to do with the fact that you
growing up in lebanon you feel like
i remember the teacher used to tell us
in school you see that very
invisible
dot on the map this is lebanon
so you feel like you're coming from a
very small
invisible
place
you feel like nothing
you can never really achieve anything
great or anything good because you come
from such a small country and you're
almost invisible you feel really
invisible
so really when you stop when you start
actually
achieving things you it's almost
unbelievable it almost
feels like a fairy tale so the first
time we went to khan it was also you
know very a very
amazing
um
uh memory for me because a few years
back i used to go to can as a as just
you know a student or a normal
spectator and i used to beg people to
get an invitation to go watch a film and
can is very hard it's very harsh
so then going there with your own film
and the doors being open and being
considered like you're part of the
family is something that is almost
unbelievable until now
so um
then uh
let me see where i am in my notes
um so with time so i okay i wrote my
first film i wrote my second and i did
my first film and i wrote my second film
and i did
also
my second film was called where do we go
now and also it went to khan but then
with my
third one
which is the most recent one capernaum
i started feeling the need
to research i started before writing i
started because
you know
being now in a world that
where nothing is really going the right
way you feel like the right way you feel
like you're living in a chaos
and especially living in lebanon
lebanon being a country that you know
now is hosting over a million and a half
syrian refugee and also again being a
very small country that is already
facing its own economical problems
you feel the chaos all around you
those the sight of those children
on the streets
either begging or working
the sight of
those communities of people completely
invisible
treated as if they're you know not there
treated as if they don't exist
uh those images of those children uh you
know over the internet whether
the child that i don't know if you
remember that was found dead on the
shores of turkey
a few years back
the image of those children
dying from chemical weapons in syria or
you know hearing about those children
that the children that are being
separated from
from their families on the on the
mexican border i feel like there's a lot
of things
that we need to
uh
defend in a way i felt like i can't
really be
silent anymore
because by being silent i am almost
part of it i'm almost part of of the
crime it's like
um
it's it's it's one of the biggest crimes
i don't know how how i don't know how
we're not
uh now actually
all of us on the streets
[Music]
manifested what's the word
sorry
first testing yes
for it um
so i felt you know i when i saw this
image of this child uh on the shores of
turkey i thought
if he
was able to talk
if he were to talk what would he tell us
what would he
say to the world that is actually
you know doing this to him what did he
feel you know the moment he fell in the
water
what were his dreams what did he think
at that moment
uh what did he did he know where he was
going did he know what was what what
what was the adventure that he was
embarking on
what how does this boy that is standing
next to my
car window looking at me not looking at
him how does he how does he feel to be
completely
invisible how does it he feel to be
completely non-existent because this is
what we usually do unfortunately we
we tend to not look because sometimes
the problem is is too big
we feel like we can't do anything about
it so we choose to continue to continue
our lives
so i felt responsible in a way i felt i
i i i can't
just
continue being silent so i want to talk
about this
and i was coming back home um
one night and i saw it another child
also
sitting on a cement block it was like
one o'clock in the morning and he was it
was at the traffic light and he was just
dozing off not being able to sleep and
he was like about one or one and a half
years old
and i came back home and i drew a
picture of a child
shouting at adults
and this
actually picture
became
my
latest film capernaum it became the
story of
of a child who was going to
sue his parents for giving him life
because it was
inspired by all the research that we
were doing to go back to the the
research
process that i was talking to about it
was very important
in order to to start becoming
the vehicle for these children to
express themselves because this is what
i felt like doing i wanted to become
their voice in a way i wanted to be able
to understand exactly
what goes on
in their heads what is the behind the
scenes of of their life what happens
when this child disappears around the
corner and he i don't see him anymore
where does she go who is his family
so we started this whole research
process and i knew how important this
research process is because i felt that
i was not actually entitled
to
invent that story i wasn't i haven't
been there i haven't been in those shoes
so i i'm not entitled to come up with a
story i'm not entitled to fantasize the
story i have to know
what the real story is and this is my
mission is actually to capture this
and
and put a magnifying glass on it
and in a way humanize it because of
course we hear about it in the news and
we treat it as if it was some kind of
big abstract problem but we forget to
sometimes
put a face on the problem and and
actually i think cinema can have a much
uh has has this bigger mission actually
to humanize the problem to
to put a face on the problem it it has
the face of a of a child or of a of a of
a woman or of a man struggling and
actually it can have a a completely
different impact on you as a human being
when you know that this is an actual
struggle this is actually somebody who's
having that same struggle in their real
life
uh
so um
we started this this this research going
everywhere in lebanon you know going to
the most unfortunate places to the most
difficult neighborhood talking to lots
of children and also trying to
understand the point of view of the
parents also talking to lots of parents
also trying to understand the point of
view of justice how does the justice
system work
we spent so much time in in courts uh
trying just observing how does this
justice system work
uh when it's facing a child whether the
child is there because he needs
protection or because he's committed
some kind of criminal act or
and we saw lots of children and spoke to
lots of children and we're talking about
children who are facing extreme neglect
we're not talking about
uh
you know any unhappy children talking
about children who have been abused
who've been raped who've been
who've been
tortured children have been beaten up a
lot
children who
never hear a nice word so
so so i just
translated started translated those
discussions that we used to have
into
this
story
translating the way they were angry
because i used to ask them one question
at the end of the conversation which is
are you happy to be alive and most of
the times unfortunately the answer would
be no i'm not happy to be here i'm i
wish i was dead i don't know why i'm
here if nobody's going to love me if i'm
going to be beaten up every day if i'm
going to be raped if i'm going to be why
why why this this is angry why all the
time why am i here
so i i started you know translating this
trying to translate it and and that's
how it became the story of the child who
was going to sue the world actually for
bringing him to this life and not giving
him that his most fundamental rights
so so during the
um during the the
uh
the re the research process i knew
that i was going to be working with
non-professional actors
actors who are not really actors people
who are are are living that same
struggle i knew that it was important
for me to become in a way to create a
platform
through my film
uh to create a platform for them to
express themselves so we used to go on
this research every day and come back
home
and you know debate and
and
remember the scenes remember the
dialogues remember you know details
small details that we used to see
and started weaving them into
a story
so it's the whole story of capernaum is
actually a mix
yes a mixture of everything and all the
scenes that you used to see and we of
course it started with wanting
to talk about a child and and and child
labor and a child not not receiving his
most fundamental rights but then slowly
we understood that
you can't talk about
child labor without talking about
paperless children you can't talk about
paperless children without talking about
uh the the the
um
um
the absurdity of having to have a paper
to prove that you exist
uh the absurdity of borders without
talking about the syrian refugee crisis
or the refugee crisis overall without
talking about
[Music]
modern slavery without talking about
human trafficking without talking about
early marriage everything in a way we
understood that everything was was
intertwined everything was all the
problems were so intricately
um
related to each other and in each family
even if some people say find it
sometimes that it's too much there's too
many things we're talking about too many
themes in the film but it's actually the
reality
uh those things can actually happen
in one single family
so understanding this
it was impossible
like i told you not to talk about
everything so we started weaving all
those themes
into that story
so we had a very solid story at the end
of you know and based on everything we
used to see at the end of those three
years
but then working with non-professional
actors i knew that we needed also to
give them
the space because they're not
professional actors it's impossible
to um
actually impose on them a text or
or expect that they
uh memorize the text and that they say
it in a natural way it was actually
killing the process so for me
it was very important
to give them time to give them space to
give to be able to adapt to their own
personality and not really impose
whatever we had written on them so it
was a very
it was a sort of a you know choreography
a negotiation between their reality
and the fiction that we
had written so the film was actually
being rewritten
while we were shooting
um
and this
means
uh
really it was a collaborative process
they are part
of
the
writing process
and you have to
be able to allow them
in a way time was very important this is
why we shot for so long we saw it for
six months and we
have over 500 hours of rushes
so you have to give them the time
to understand what they were doing you
have to be able in a way to become
invisible and not to paralyze them so
this means no marks this means
a
natural light most of the time
this means intervening the least
possible this means shooting in natural
location this means
[Music]
being
in a way trying to become invisible in
order for them not to feel your presence
anymore
it means
giving them wings by by making them feel
how what they have to say is important
because of course in the beginning
they're very shy they don't know they
they don't know if anyway they're
struggling in their real life to even
exist
so how can whatever they have to say be
important to anyone so they feel like
they're you know whatever they have to
say is not important so you have to
create this sort of relationship for
them to trust you and for them to start
feeling that they
have the right to actually
express themselves freely
so you have to really
work capture their reality and then
in a way navigate it towards the fiction
that was written so it was an ongoing
process all the time of rewriting
so and it also means guiding them
through the take
and letting
letting it evolve you know evolve
organically it means also having to talk
also the whole time which is very very
problematic for the
it was a nightmare for of course the
editors to actually take my voice out
because you have to you know guide them
through it the whole time and this meant
also um
[Music]
shooting uh
very long takes uh and it meant also
having an amazing crew of people that
really believe in what you're doing and
not
doubt
at any time
what you're doing because what we were
doing was a little bit crazy sometimes
we we used to really shoot
for hours with
the cameras on their shoulders uh boom
operators
in this position and
and you have to have a crew that really
believes in what you're doing in order
for them to
uh
to stay to to just
be with you on this adventure
and i think
in a way
uh
it also
the fact that we felt
that life
art was imitating life so so so
i think closely that life started
imposing itself on us in a certain way
so we had very strange
things happening happening to us during
the shoot
like two days after the
the i don't know if you've seen it how
many of you have seen capernaum
yes so for the people who have seen it
you know there's a scene where uh where
where she's uh raheel is being captured
because she doesn't have any any papers
so two days after we shoot that scene
rahel is captured in real life for
exactly the same reasons and so she
lives she goes through exactly this
almost the same situations and and the
father and mother of the child that is
in the film yonah so it's actually a
girl in real life her name is treasure
are arrested with her at the same time
so when we were shooting those scenes
with treasure
where treasure is without her mother she
was actually in reality without her
mother
so you
in a way you start feeling that you're
actually
capturing reality and it starts it
starts also
having a very big impact on on you as a
human being capturing that moment you
don't know anymore what you're doing is
this a film is this reality and this
kept really happening the whole time
with us
and and i think
uh because we also wanted to allow it we
wanted to embrace also whatever life was
going to bring our way it meant not
being afraid of
of just uh walking outside you know the
the the paved ways in a way walking
outside outside the box
it's meant also shooting things not
being afraid of you know continuity
because the fear of continuity usually
is a very big fear and and we sometimes
used to because you can't expect
especially when you're working with
children you can't expect them to do
what you want them to do exactly at the
time you want them to do it
so you really have to be
uh adaptable and sometimes you you
should shoot a certain certain uh scenes
that were not supposed to happen
uh at the time that we were shooting
them but because you know it was
adequate we used to and then and then we
used to take it and put it in a
different scene and we had lots of lots
of um
scenes that where where you don't really
see it but there's a big continuity
problem they are actually wearing
different clothes they are actually
but you don't really feel it because
you're so drawn into the i think what's
happening in the scene that you don't
really
notice that they're wearing different
clothes and so you need to be
you know in a way
adaptable and and really adapt to their
own rhythm and not expect them to adapt
to your way of working or to your um
your your your mison san or a certain
camera movement
so that's why um i was talking about uh
allowing also reality
uh uh to to take you know to to give us
uh or or to in a way to impose itself on
us and really life to and embrace
whatever's
happens this is something i will talk
about later about you know having to
take out everything lots lots of very
interesting things actually the first
uh version of the film was 12 hours
yes and and i still find it very hard
now to say this is the last edit of the
film i'm still editing it in my head the
whole time and i keep waking up my
husband every night and saying what do
you think we should have done that
and he thinks like it's a nightmare he's
also
the producer of the film and the music
composer of the film and
it keeps haunting me because of those
very precious
real moments that unfortunately we we
we've put a lot of them but we can we
couldn't put everything
um so that was a an example to just to
show you how sometimes you know
it doesn't have to be so structured it
doesn't have to be
we can actually shoot with the sound
with everything else going on and just
you need to really know what you're
doing that's why it's very important
that you can't really improvise when if
if you don't know what you're doing it
doesn't
you need to have to start from from a
very solid script and actually eric
dolphy once said that it's like jazz you
can only improvise when you really know
the music you need a very strong
foundation in order to be free
so i think that's what we used to do
it's very important that you have this
very strong
foundation which is the script you know
where you're starting
when you're going what's your story but
then within it you're not afraid to just
improvise and get out of of of the paved
ways
because you know where you're going
um
what else do i want to tell you
yes so so for for some people it sounds
for some people it sounds like chaos and
actually the word capernaum means chaos
but
it also means miracles so
things like that used to happen all the
time and
i'll tell you about a small miracle also
uh at the end of of of our talk but
small miracles used to happen like this
all the time during the shoot in the
midst of of of all this chaos
um
and there's another very important
ingredient when you're doing this when
you're improvising and when you're
working with non-professional actors it
that it might sound a little bit naive
but it's actually love
really loving your characters being
fascinated by them by who they are
building their this distrust
relationship because i'm also maybe in a
way fascinated with human behavior
i'm fascinated with how uh you know we
react to certain things towards certain
things and how it feels to be in someone
else's shoes maybe it's because i'm also
bored
with my own personality because i want
to explore my other natures and i truly
believe that there are
other natures in every one of us
and actually it's the only place where
it's cinema is only the only place where
it's actually legal for you and
legitimate for you to explore your other
natures otherwise in real life you're
labeled as crazy you cannot be you know
uh reacting differently
uh every day
so i think to a lot of people who work
in this in this
industry who are filmmakers
screenwriters actors i think we love our
jobs because it also allows us to get
away from from ourselves to get get away
from maybe the boredom from of our own
personalities
because because we need to explore
our other natures
and actually the fact that we also shot
chronologically for such a long time
allowed them to be able to really grasp
their story and understand it and and
grow with it
uh actually jonas the the treasure her
name is treasure the little girl
actually she made her real first steps
during the the the shooting of the film
so the the children were growing their
parents were growing
everybody we were growing
by
uh as as
as a crew
by everything we used to see and it was
very
difficult to know that we're actually
grasping real moments we're actually
shooting
kausa lives in those slums that you see
in the film her house is actually one of
the houses
this shot where the camera goes out and
up and you see all the tires on the
on those houses and the tiles her house
is actually one of those houses
so we used to go there shoot in
their neighborhoods sit on their sofas
eat their food breathe
the same air
share so many things during the shoot
but then
we used to go home and sleep in a warm
bed
so it was actually very difficult
emotionally to do that every day to know
that we're there in their reality but
then
we're leaving them there
um
so it was
very nurturing also the whole process of
spending so much time and understanding
it and really living there with with
their problems almost shooting in the
sewers we were shooting in the swords
because unfortunately this is the
reality and having you know the voices
and the cries of those children around
us all the time
as if it was like a background
sound
of children crying the whole time that
we were shooting there
um
[Music]
so now we go to the
editing phase and the editing phase is
actually uh the the the the
the place where with the phase where we
rewrite the film for the third time
and it's really the most difficult
decision-making
process especially
when you have over 500 hours of rushes
and that you have like every bit of it
and
and that the first version like i told
you is 12 hours it's a nightmare when
you know
that the film when you're editing that
the film can actually take so many
different directions and it can take so
many different structures it doesn't
have to be the way you had written it it
can be
rewritten it can have a different
structure and and it's very difficult to
take those decisions
and i think
as filmmakers
and as screenwriters we're lacking one
very crucial element
one actually gift that is so
i think that is usually a blessing
we're like we don't have this gift of
actually watching the film as if we're
seeing it
for the first time like any normal
viewer
this is something that we will never be
able to achieve
and it's actually only then that you are
able as a filmmaker to take the right
decisions and i went to so many
different things i went to crazy stuff i
i actually tried
hypnosis uh in order to yes in order to
try to forget
the film
so i i i i spoke to a friend of mine who
does it i told her can you make me
forget everything about the film for
only two hours and make me just watch
this film as if i'm seeing it for the
first time like any normal viewer who's
watching the film for the first time you
don't know you're crazy you can't
so i really couldn't
and so we what we did also
um it's it's really it's really
difficult
to take decisions when you are so
uh i think um
when you've been diving in this
adventure for such a long time the whole
process to
two years of editing six months of
shooting three years of research so the
whole thing took like four years of my
life where i was working on this every
single day so it's difficult to really
have the distance that you need
in order to take the right decisions
so i did a lot of
screenings test screenings where we used
to listen to really everybody's opinion
take notes and listen and analyze and
see why without really interfering and
or and trying to convince anyone of the
opposite
opinion i just wanted to
understand how does a person who is
seeing this film for the first time
perceive it what are the flaws what are
and it's very important it helps a lot
but still
i'm still
not able
to
say i am done
i'm not able to say to let go and say
that's it
that's the finished pro
product
because i know that so many beautiful
precious moments inside those 500 hours
that are not there and that maybe i will
never be able to share
with anyone
so you keep
this never really you never have peace
in a way
when you're making a film i i think i'm
not the only one i think a lot of lots
of filmmakers
go through this and
and i'm sure
if you ask many of them they would tell
you yes i wish i can
re-edit my film 10 years later
so i think
now i've understood that maybe in the
process maybe the next time if i find a
producer who's crazy enough to do this
maybe take a year off
like do a first
first edit of the film
take six months off maybe even a year
off do something else
you know wash my eyes work on another
project
and then go back and rediscover that
film and that edit
with with fresh eyes i think it's the
most you know precious thing that
that that can actually enlighten
um
you as a filmmaker you've been diving so
much in in your
in your material
um
uh
[Music]
i don't know what else i want to tell
you
i told you about waking up
in the middle of the night
i yes i want to tell you also that like
i told you that the title of the film
capernaum means chaos and
and miracles
and i told you that miracles kept
happening the whole time and now when i
looked at when i look at zayn's smile at
the end of the film
it has a completely different meaning
for me because now
zayn who's been living almost the same
circumstances
has
a norwegian passport now he's been
resettled in norway he's living a
completely different life he's going to
school he's regained his childhood and
and and life keeps reminding me in a way
that i don't know what it is but
in the film zayn used to dream of going
to sweden now he's in norway
in the film um
rahil and her son
get deported
they are now back they were deported and
they are now in in kenya
in the film
i don't remember what else but
reality keeps you know haunting us in a
way and reminding us that what we were
doing was not actually just another film
and
that's it and i think another miracle is
actually me standing here giving a
lecture
about my film being among all those
amazing you know filmmakers and
screenwriters is actually yes another
miracle so thank you for listening
[Applause]
i don't know if i was too long no that
was perfect thank you so much i'm going
to fundamentally disagree with two
things that you said one is that you are
not a screenwriter and the other is that
you're not a lecturer because you're
clearly both of those things thank you
so much that's amazing um i've got so
much i want to ask you about and i know
that lots of people will have two so
we'll get straight on with it
just
explain to us with this last film
did was there ever a point when you had
an actual script
yes of course
before you started and then you just
stole things as you went along yes
absolutely there was a very very solid
script
and i think you can't really
expect to improvise
you know
not knowing where you're going and
really succeed in doing that it's very
difficult it's only when you really know
your material very very well that you
allow yourself to improvise because it's
not scary anymore you know where you're
going you know what you're going to keep
from that what is good what is actually
adding some kind of value to what you've
written and what you don't really need
and what you want to say because you
know what the scene has to tell
you know where you're starting where it
needs to land and what the scene needs
to tell as a story you know what you
want so it's actually
not scary anymore to improvise because
you know what you will keep and what you
will not keep and it's actually
also nurturing because
it's very for me at least i'm not saying
this again it doesn't apply to to other
filmmakers of course but for me
it's more challenging that way i'm not
interested in just
sticking to what i had written
because i need to in a way discover
things and be surprised
and this surprise element keeps you
going gives you so much adrenaline when
you're working and when you're actually
thinking that was a real moment
this is not something i've written or
imagined or
or fantasized about this is a reality
especially when you're trying to
make a film that is
in a way the closest possible to reality
and it's the biggest compliment for me
when people tell me i thought i was
i was looking at a documentary but then
i understood it was a fiction
because this is what i wanted to achieve
i really
because i think cinema can have a much
bigger impact on you as a as a viewer
when you're really thinking that this is
an actual struggle and you're really not
thinking it it's actually feeling it
you know that this is zayn's life when
you're watching it you know that this is
like
life when you're watching it you know
it's not make relief
can you imagine now you've had this
experience which must have been really
different from the experiences on the
other two films
can you imagine going back to a more
conventional sort of sitting down with a
blank piece of paper and
starting from scratch or will you always
now have an element of this in the works
i think yes i think in a way when you
when you go this path it's difficult to
go back
it's difficult to unless you know i i
it's a complete you know fantasy or film
that is like i don't know
something that is very very
decaleigh from from real life or
different from your life then yes but
if if i want to continue doing that kind
of cinema it's difficult
at least i know now how precious
research is
how precious and how confidence it gives
you
how much confidence it gives you when
you're actually knowing that
this is actually what you're saying is
true it's not you're not inventing a
story you're not
um
i'm not saying this doesn't apply to all
kinds of old schools of filmmaking
it really applies to this kind of
filmmaking that i am into right now it
doesn't mean that other kinds of films
that are you know completely fantasized
are not great there's masterpieces
uh like that but uh for now i think i'm
i'm interested in that i don't know how
how long i will keep doing it maybe one
day i will shift completely
but i'm interested in in in reflecting
reality i'm interesting in interested in
telling real stories i'm interested in
in showing real struggles because i
think it's it's not even
it's not even a choice for me in a way
it's a duty i don't know why i feel this
maybe living in lebanon and growing up
in lebanon and in such a difficult
complicated
country where nothing is is is going the
way it should sometimes i feel like it's
a cursed
region
i mean that's why also the film is
called capernaum
is a cursed
village to curse by jesus and there used
to be a lot of miracles happening there
so it's a mixture between curse and
chaos and miracles so
so i feel i feel the responsibility of
being and
and an artist living in lebanon you feel
like it's a duty
to to use your tool to actually
make some kind of change or at least if
you if you can't achieve change at least
trigger
debate
[Music]
it's not a choice
for me i need to do that
i feel it i feel that mission for now
you feel it for now you didn't always
feel that did you no you set out to make
cameras where is that yes you it grew
and it feels like everyone else yes
absolutely i think it i think it's
something that comes with age with
maturity with
with motherhood with
becoming feeling or or wanting to be
more politically engaged or socially
engaged
this comes with time it comes with
maturity i didn't know
what i was doing when i was making my
first film i didn't know what really
worked for me i was learning really my
craft while i was making my first film
so you don't now i know that i need time
when i'm working on a film to be able
really to to draw these kinds of
performances from non-professional
actors and children or i need i need to
i need this organized chaos this
organized chaos actually
i don't know gives me adrenaline
charges me with something i cannot do
things that are very structured i cannot
be paralyzed in the classical way of
making films
it it i don't know why it in a way it
scares me it kills me do you think you
could have done this had you not had
those earlier experiences of a more
conventional
absolutely not i need i needed those
other experiences
to learn what works for me
it doesn't mean that
i i love my other two films but it was a
completely different uh
had a completely different personality
even i changed for me there was a before
and after
capernaum for me i changed humanly i
mean
i changed even physically i changed it
was so challenging it was so
so um
uh yeah
you talked a little bit about i mean you
talked a lot about being a writer you
talked a lot about being a director
a little bit about being a producer as
well yes the other bit of your kind of
hybrid and which makes you a little bit
unusual in this series is that you're
also an actor
um and that's how you started do you
think that that made you has made you a
different kind of writer
absolutely i think the fact that you
know actors
well because you are also in the shoes
of an actor a lot of times i think you
know what an actor needs you know how an
actor expects to be directed you know
what an actor expects
also
from a script he's reading i think it
enriches you on so many levels
everything being a director an actor
producer writer
i think for me i can't really divide
myself for me i'm just all of those
things together and it really
makes me see
this
this whole thing from so many different
perspectives
and it informs each each job actually
informs the other one in a in a positive
way
uh and also being an a director i i work
differently also with actors because i
was also an actor
so the relationship between the director
and actor becomes much more
strong
when you know
what the actor needs from a director and
what the director needs from an actor
and being both of them
you know and it actually i think creates
a much better
relationship for me as an actor with any
any director because i understand the
director i know what he feels i know the
his you know his sort of
fragility i don't know if you know uh i
know i know when to talk to a director
when not to talk when to propose
something when not to propose when to
shake his is you know um
in a way this his confidence when not to
do it you really become very delicate in
in in that way
and when you were writing for you
presumably for the first two films you
knew the part you were writing was going
to be taken by you yes does that make
you write it in a different way i mean
i i don't uh actually when i think about
it i don't enjoy it very well because
i'm afraid the writing also the writing
for myself because i'm always afraid to
challenge myself as an actor i'm not i
don't have enough confidence
to challenge myself as an actor or to
say i'm gonna you know give myself a
very challenging part and really
explore my other natures the way i
really want to explore them because i
don't have enough confidence i didn't
start as an actor i started as a
filmmaker and then i started acting in
my own films because i felt the need to
do it i felt close to those characters
so i did it but i don't write
challenging parts for myself because i'm
afraid
and in this one i was in capernaum
actually i was the most afraid and
and
the the part was
much more written than this and and we
shot those scenes with the lawyer and
the film you understand where she's
coming from why she's defending zayn
what is her story what is her struggle
you go to her house
you understand her pain and all that but
then when i started editing the film i
felt that i was the only lie in the film
i was the only person that was an actor
i
was not a lawyer in real life
so it was a sort of a small lie that's
why we took everything out
and we kept those small scenes you you
barely see me for one minute in the film
we kept those small scenes just to
understand how zayn was able to actually
file a complaint and stand in front of
the of a judge
so for me
it's very difficult i as much as i love
acting
uh it's very difficult to write
interesting characters for myself
i don't know if i will ever be able to
do it
but
i'd love to because i have never really
experienced that
amazing relationship between an actor
and director where you really dig into
your personality and you challenge
yourself and you explore those other
natures that are inside you know that
they're inside but you don't know how to
you're afraid to
you're afraid to let them out and you
really need
the love
and the desire of somebody else
to
actually
be able to let them
out
and could you ever imagine writing for
somebody else
writing for somebody else to direct
um
or is it all just
writing for somebody else to direct no i
can't i
can't i can't really let go no it's
impossible
no i don't imagine myself doing it it's
interesting though because your first
two films particularly i mean a lot of
the com you know the reception of those
two films was around the the uh the
genre how you treat a genre particularly
that these were i think caramel they
described as an international rom-com
somebody somebody i was reading a great
review this morning which said that it
was still magnolias without the terminal
illness
but but you know
a lot of that is quite a conventional
way of you know
pulling apart a subject and putting it
back together again
do you really not think you could do
that for somebody else or are you just
not interested in doing that for
somebody else i've never really thought
about it
uh i've never really thought about it i
think i'm too
jealous in a way not jealous but yes i'm
too
possessive
over
i don't know what i write and what i do
that it's difficult to just let go and
say you know
you can do it
i've never thought about it it's a very
good question
somebody will ask um and the other thing
i i know we've only got a few minutes
left actually so i'm going to go to
questions very shortly but just just let
me just ask
do you think there is still a through
line between your
various different films i mean the three
could not be more different i don't
think you know the subjects the way that
you uh have put them together and and
the way they've come out do you see
a clear sort of you know is there is
there your personality in all three of
your films do you still see that yes
absolutely i think
i think the relationship to actors this
way of directing actors this way of
working almost all the time with
non-professional actors because i did
this with caramel also almost all of
them were non-professional actors except
the policemen i think yes and and where
do we go now also there were maybe two
or three actors in the film but the rest
were not professional actors
also the that relationship with actors
you feel it this this this way of draw
that's that's my i think my
my strongest my favorite
my favorite thing about filmmaking
actually is really drawing
great performances out of people who
have never acted in their lives and
really having this kind of fascination
um towards their personalities in real
life and it shows really it showed that
there's a fascination because the way we
shoot them the whole time the way we the
way we in in a way magnify
their personality
you can really see it you can really
feel it it's like the secret code that i
have with my actors this is something i
think that shows in in all of the films
i guess and also maybe you know the
humor
part you know finding humor in the most
difficult situations in the most absurd
situations
also is something that
i like doing
i don't know actually if when you see
caramel and when you see capernaum you
say i know it's the same person doing
those things those two films
i don't know
i think capernaum is very very different
in the way
and
it's harsher it's more
it's less
but i don't know if you really see
through it and you see me in in all of
them as as a normal viewer that doesn't
know
i think also
the the interest that you previously
have had in telling stories about women
particularly in the first two films and
then you've moved slightly to the side
of that is that is that a kind of i mean
did you consciously set out to make
films about women in the first place and
then you have moved away no is that just
an accident no not at all i think i i
was it was natural for me in the first
film because i was also
uh you know
trying to understand women in my country
trying to understand the contradiction
that i used to see all the time
contradiction between what those women
actually
allowed themselves to be when they had
different dreams you know the
contradiction between who you end up
becoming
and what you wanted to become and are
trying to understand why is there so
much contradiction why aren't we able to
actually
be who we want to be
uh of course because of social pressure
so many different different
reasons
i just decided to
talk about this because i felt the need
to talk about it i felt the need to
understand through those examples of
different women coming from different
backgrounds different educations
different stories different experiences
as if i was drawing you know um
you know
it's not really a resume it's not really
a summary
of of all the women for women but it was
you know seeing it from from different
perspectives and trying to understand
women from different ages and all that
because i needed to understand also i
was looking around me actually it was at
a point where i was looking around me at
women and i felt
sadness in most of the women
i knew
there was a sort of sadness in their
eyes
i never
had encountered a woman that was
actually completely fulfilled
or fulfilling herself i was actually
looking for a wall a role model and i
couldn't find it
and i started asking my question myself
the question that's why i started
working on this pheromone
um
and the same thing for where do we go
now it was actually also
a time where i was
you know i was pregnant with my first
baby and conflicts erupted in lebanon
and there were conflicts that you know
erupted over a period a very very short
period of time like three hours or four
hours and all of a sudden
beirut was actually on the verge of a
new civil war lebanon was actually on
the verge of a new civil war so i felt
you know at that time what would i do as
a mother to stop my son from taking a
weapon and going down to down the
streets and
and killing somebody else's
another woman's son
what would i do as a mother
and that's how it started
it became the story of those women who
were going to stop their men from
fighting
so it actually always comes from a need
in a way a need to express something and
need to
or
something that becomes an obsession
something that you is always on your
mind you're always thinking about it and
then you express it and you turn it into
a film
uh
this is this is what i know that's my
tool and it was the same thing for this
film uh it was really the need to
to just um
stop being silent
felt the duty to just talk about this
problem
and because it's a really we're not
talking about hundreds of children or
thousands of children we're talking
about millions of children across the
world that are deprived from their most
basic rights and that was the ignition
point of course then later i i i spoke
about many different themes but but the
igniting point with what really this
there's over 280 million children across
the world that work
that don't go to school
that are living in
in unbearable conditions
those children are those children are
growing up angry they're growing up
numb most of the time i saw kids that
don't
don't react anymore they've been in such
a state of shock they don't they don't
they don't do anything they don't laugh
they don't cry they don't dance they
don't play they don't do anything
they've been so
uh
traumatized so beaten up so raped so
abused that they are numb
those children growing up numb we have
to
we have to just be aware of the problem
that we're going to face in a few years
where
you know this is going to explode in our
faces one day
so i just felt the need to talk about it
as simple as that
it doesn't come from you know wanting
analyzing oh now i'm going to talk about
women
i'm glad you did um okay we've got time
for just a couple of questions i'm
afraid pop your hands up one down here
and then one down here
thank you very much for your lecture
thank you very much for your lecture
nadine
um i just wanted to ask you how the
actors felt about the characters that
you had created that are obviously very
very close to their reality but when you
think for example the woman who played
swat it's a pretty tough mirror of
motherhood that you put in front of her
did she express the need to not do
certain things or change the character
you know what was their relationship or
even little zayn like all these
beautiful swear words that he uses
through the film did it come naturally
from him how much comes from you just
trying to understand that dynamic
uh
the i think the fact that they were felt
that they were part of a mission
allowed them
to really do everything they were doing
in the film
kausar saad mother of zayn actually felt
the need to express it because this is
something that she sees around her
she was actually inspired by someone in
her family everything that she was doing
was inspired by someone in her family so
she felt the need to express it because
she felt she was part of that mission
everybody that was in the film was
actually collaborating in that mission
zayn was doing the same thing
zayn felt that he was being the voice of
those voiceless kids that he used to
meet every day or see every day struggle
because zayn is coming from the same
background saying used to you know he
never went to school he's a syrian
refugee he's been living in lebanon
under very very difficult circumstances
in a very dangerous neighborhood so he
used to struggle every day to survive
you know getting into fights
those swear words are his own swear
words this is the way he talks this is
her his personality and i i i was it was
very important for me to keep them and
to keep his personality because this was
one of the most
i think important signs of the violence
he used to
he used to
go through
that's where you know what this kid is
has gone through it's by the language
that he uses and this is nothing
compared to zayn's language it's nothing
when you hear zayn when you hear him
getting into a fight and fighting with
his friends you'd say
how does he learn where did he learn
those things what did this child see
to be able to express himself this way
so this was very important to keep it
because this is instead of you know
showing him getting into a fight you
just keep everything the way it is and
you understand everything and you
understand everything that he's been
through and he felt he was part of a
mission you know when he's talking about
when he
calls the tv show and he says
life is worse than the shoe i'm wearing
i've never heard a nice what am i going
to remember the hoes or the chains or
the he was actually talking about
things that he had seen talking about
children that he had seen getting beaten
up he actually when he's talking about
alia when he's saying to his sister do
you know alia your friend
her mother put her in the house uh until
that pig came to came he's actually
talking about a real alia
that he knows
so he felt he was part of the mission
so he he we were all in it together
nobody felt like it was something
imposed on them or they're doing
something that they don't want to do
they they know that they need to be for
for things for their life to change they
need to talk about it
and they were collaborating in the
process
uh hello nadine first of all i watched
the film kavanaugh and it's amazing and
i can tell you like i watched all your
films first of all i'm lebanese as well
so excellent
[Laughter]
so kavanagh is different than
the first two in in so many ways my my
curiosity here lies by you being a
filmmaker you want to do the casting how
were you able like i know you took them
from real situations but how were you
able to say that zayn is zayn he is
perfect for this role
and this one is perfect for this role
did you do a normal casting were you
able how did you cast them
and something else the last thing in the
film when zayn is talking on the phone
and he's telling this whole speech that
you're talking about was it improvised
or was it written because he delivered i
think the best performance in the film
in that speech in particular
okay so for the first question the
casting was like a wild street casting
so i had an amazing crew
of five to six people that used to go
everywhere in lebanon to very you know
difficult neighborhoods
and and interview uh children and their
parents and and just
just we never you know you don't expect
them to come to
audition you have to go
to them so that's how it happened and
zayn was actually playing on the streets
with his friends he was feeding
the chickens and and the casting
director saw him and she interviewed him
and when i saw him actually there was
another
story a nice story i don't know if we
have sometimes that
um
when you know remember when i told you
when i came back home and i drew that
picture when i saw this kid trying to
sleep and i drew this picture of this
child that is
shouting at adults and he has his his
mouth wide open and he's shouting
when i compare
this drawing to zayn's picture it was
actually zayn four years before i met
him
so
it's something
that tells you
everything he is actually
the fact that he's it was actually when
you see i forgot this actually i wanted
to read to you the description of zayn
and i forgot it the description of zin
in the in the script
he is described exactly the same way
that he has to be
uh smaller than his age because of the
malnutrition he has to have those eyes
that those sad eyes that show you that
you know he's been a witness to so many
things this wisdom and his personality
because he's lost his child on his own
he's seen so many things that he's not a
child anymore everything in the
description was actually when we saw
zayn it was zayn and and it was obvious
that um
i mean it took me like two
the the second answer he gave her i knew
that it was him
and i never you know doubted it and it
was like this for almost everyone in the
film
it's something in you like like
like love at first sight it's like a
fascination for
their character in in their real life
that tells you you're on the right path
even if sometimes you have doubts and
it's difficult and you don't know the
first day of the shoot with the parents
with zane's parents i thought what have
i done
this is this is a complete failure
but then i don't know like a miracle the
next day because you give them the
strength and you talk and you talk and
you explain why
and you give them wings and and they
start feeling because
you know a few days before being on set
they were actually struggling to prove
they even exist none of them have papers
legally not only emotionally they don't
exist but even legally they don't exist
so all of a sudden they are here they
feel important what they have to say
actually counts for somebody and it gave
them wings and the next day it was i
don't know
another miracle i couldn't believe what
they were able
to do
um and what was the other question
the last speech that yes no it was
written but it was also uh
very adapted to his words so that's what
we used to do all the time so of course
you guide him into
saying things
in the way i mean towards what you want
but
he also uses his own words so it's a
mixture between what was written and a
few words that he had that he added it's
always like that
we were talking before we came out here
tonight about this afternoon about how
this series tells you that there's kind
of a million ways to make a movie and
i'm so glad that we got to hear about
the way that you make them thank you so
much for coming
[Applause]
you